what we're going to do in this video is
talk about hypothesis testing which is
the heart of all of inferential
statistics statistics that allow us to
make inferences about the world so to
give us the gist of this let's start
with a tangible example let's say
hypothetically you run a website that
has the mission of giving everyone on
the planet a free education and you want
to think about how you might change the
amount of time people spend on the site
ideally you want to increase the amount
of time people spend on the site so
there's more learning on the planet well
currently the website has a white
background like this and the mean amount
of time people spend when you have a
white background the mean amount of time
when you have a white background is 20
minutes and you are someone on your team
maybe you read some type of study that's
like that says if people like to spend
more time on yellow backgrounds I don't
actually think that's true but let's
just go with that for the sake of this
video and so you have a hypothesis that
if you actually have a yellow background
if you change your background to yellow
that the mean amount of time that people
spend on a yellow background on yellow
is going to be different is not going to
be equal to the mean amount of time
people spend on a white background so
the question is how do you test this and
how do you feel good about your
inferences that you make from your test
and that is the heart of hypothesis
testing and medical research actually
almost all research involves to some
form of hypothesis testing so how would
you do this well the standard way to do
this is to set up a couple of hypothesis
hypotheses I should say the first one is
known as your null hypothesis and I
often think about this as the skeptics
hypothesis skeptics think that hey it's
hard to make a difference in this world
or cynics feel like it's hard to make a
difference in the world and so they
always have this null hypothesis this
thing hey you think you're making a
difference but you aren't so the null
hypothesis is that the mean amount of
time people spend on the yellow site on
or on a yellow site is going to be equal
to
the mean amount of time that people
spend on the current side or the
existing site or on a white site while
the people who are thinking about hey
how do we make change how do I make
improvements in the world they had some
type of hypothesis and we call that the
alternative alternative hypothesis and
so the alternative hypothesis a four
alternative is that the mean time on the
yellow site on the yellow site is
actually different is actually different
is not equal to the mean amount of time
on the white side so how do we think
about this now that we set up these
hypotheses well what we're going to do
is we are going to assume we assume the
null hypothesis then we build this
yellow site and then we take a sample of
the people using the yellow site and we
say what is the probability of getting
that sample mean which is an
approximation of the parameter of the
true mean what is the probability of
getting that sample mean if we assume
the null hypothesis and if the
probability of getting that sample mean
on the yellow site assuming the null
hypothesis is really low then we reject
the null hypothesis which suggests the
alternative on the other hand if we get
a sample mean that seems pretty
reasonable to get if you assume the null
hypothesis then we fail to reject the
null hypothesis and then that would not
suggest the alternative now to make this
a little bit more tangible and we'll go
over this into a lot of videos if you
assume the null hypothesis then there's
a few things you can think about you can
think about just the general
distribution of the amount of time
people spend on the site it would look
something like this we will for this
sake assume that it's a normal
distribution and normal distributions
are very important and or things that
are close to normal distributions for
hypothesis testing but let's say that
it's a normal distribution of the amount
of time people spend on the site and so
there is some mean we know that mean so
the mean that people spend on that white
site is equal to 20 min
and remember we're assuming the null
hypothesis so we're assuming that this
is also the amount of time that people
spend on the yellow site we've assumed
assuming the null hypothesis and you
could view this as time or distribution
of time spent now one of the things
we're going to talk about in future
videos is if you have this distribution
you can actually come up with a dish
another distribution of the means of
samples you might get so there's
something else called the sampling
distribution and I know it's very
confusing at first sampling distribution
of the sample of the sample mean and
it'll be forgiven sample size for sample
size sample size let's say this is
sample size 1000 I'm just making things
up I could have said n but I'm just
going to make this a little bit more
tangible well we're going to get
statistical methods for how you can
think about this distribution assuming
this distribution we have on the left
and it turns out this distribution is
going to look like the one on the left
but it's going to be narrower around
that mean it's going to look something
like this and actually the larger your
sample sizes are going to be the
narrower it's going to get now remember
this isn't just the distribution of the
amount of time people spend on the site
this is the distribution that if I were
to take a sample of the amount of time
people spend on the site and calculate
the means this is the distribution of
those sample means I might get now the
center of this distribution is still our
mean for white which is equal to the
mean for yellow remember we're assuming
the null hypothesis the mean for yellow
but each of these points like for
example if I think about this this is
amount of time that someone might spend
and you can see that there's a low
probability about it this over here this
would be a sample mean you might get
four time that you sampled a thousand
people and you calculated the mean and
you see that there's a low probability
for it so
then what you would do is if you were
able to statistically generate these
things assuming the null hypothesis and
don't worry too much we'll find out the
techniques for doing this and the
assumptions we need to make for doing
this what we do is then take a sample of
a thousand so you take your sample of a
thousand so sample 1,000 and then from
that you are able to calculate a sample
mean you are able to calculate that and
let's say you get a sample mean of 30
minutes and let's say actually that that
is right over here
that this is 30 minutes right over here
the center was 20 minutes
the next thing what you do is you say
what's the probability of getting a
result at least that extreme assuming
the null hypothesis and that high
probability on these curves it would be
this right tail here and it would be a
left tail that is equally far on the
left side so it'd be like that and what
you do is you look you look at this
probability which would be this these
yellow areas there and then we think
about the probability of getting a
result at least as Extreme as 30 minutes
so probability of getting getting a
sample mean at least as Extreme as the
sample mean equaling 30 minutes assuming
assuming your null hypothesis and that's
exactly what those yellow areas are all
about and you compare that to some pre
specified threshold so that threshold is
oftentimes 5%
sometimes it's 1% but if this
probability is less than or equal to if
it's less than or equal to your
threshold and this threshold is
oftentimes denoted by the Greek letter
alpha well we say hey that was a very
low probability of getting a result at
least at least this extreme if we assume
the null hypothesis and so that will
allow us to reject
reject the null hypothesis which would
suggest suggest the alternative notice
we haven't proven the alternative we
also haven't proven that the null
hypothesis is for sure
false we've just said if we assume the
null hypothesis there's a very low
probability of getting a result at least
as Extreme as what we just got so we
will reject the null now if it's the
other way around
if the probability of getting a sample
means at least as Extreme as this is
still reasonable if it's greater than
your pre specified threshold then you
fail to reject the null you fail to
reject your null hypothesis so I'll
leave you there in future videos we'll
go into much more depth into all of this
but this is to give to you give you a
sense of how hypothesis testing allows
science or all of us in the world to
start making inferences that we can feel
good about